and this is the master collection define
cool something that I can relate to that
I a [ __ ] oh yeah and so like if we asked
everybody I'm sure everybody's doing it
through their mind right it's a tough
thing to explain but I actually think
creative has to be cool and I think
we're who comes in for me is relevance
relevance is a very poor piece of that
relevance really mad so here's what I
think relevance + value equals where I
think that world that's all I think
about how do I bring value I could have
came up here did my thing for 45 minutes
not the life gave you the same thing
that I normally do and a lot of you
would have been pumped because you would
have said oh I finally got to see it in
person and it would have felt different
I've been shocked I'm so thankful that
people scream I ketone nine times and
still love it you know it's like that
comedian Leveson obviously Chris Rock 38
times a drug i'd get it but you know
what brings more value what we're doing
right now like you know I love Jess but
I didn't want him to like I want you to
get this this is value I think access is
going to be a very valuable thing going
forward above content but I think
relevance really matters like you know
context knowing what's happening like
you know that thing is so valuable right
and I think brands and businesses and
entrepreneurs is everybody not going to
be cool but they have to be cool the
definition it cool for the demo they're
trying to sell you just have to know
what's a while every TV back to the
people that aren't here for that it
really worked because I was reviewing
wine but I was throwing in pop culture
references that were happening in the
world at that moment that made it for
the younger demo seem a little cooler
here's a wine guy that talks about acts
like I was talking about fart you know
vast some gossip girl at its height
lot of people especially me and so you
know so I think that's where it's going
I think that the cost of being of
successful creative has been pushed very
heavy into relevance to the value and
less on just pushing something down
someone's throat thank you yeah